was, in part, due to
the fact that when they were submerged they
were undetectable by technology of the day.
Another factor that played into German hands
is that the Allies, especially the British,
consistently downplayed the danger posed by
submarines and their value in combat.
In fact, at first British Naval brass simply
refused to acknowledge that U-boats were sinking
ships.
For example, the aforementioned actions of
U-boat SM U-9 were initially attributed to
mines.
In short, British Naval officers had little
faith in the potential of submarines and wrote
them off as a mere fascination that had no
real potential in combat beyond novelty.
Thus, they did little at first to try to come
up with viable ways to combat them.
Things got real, however, when U-boats like
SM U-9 began targeting British supply ships,
almost bringing the country to its knees when
it found itself unable to secure even basic
provisions for its citizens and factories.
A solution was needed.
But how to take out a target that is capable
of disappearing at will?
It was quickly noted that one weakness of
the U-boat was that it needed to use its periscope
to mark its target before attacking.
This presented a brief, but exploitable window
of opportunity to attack the craft in some
way.
But how?
Up until the introduction of depth charges
in 1916, while mines and large nets were utilized
to protect certain areas with some minor effect,
the conclusion of the Admiralty Submarine
Attack Committee was that the best thing to
do was simply for ships to either run away
from or try to ram the U-boats when the periscope
was spotted.
Naturally, beyond risking damage to your own
vessel, getting closer to the thing that’s
about to shoot you with an otherwise somewhat
unreliably accurate torpedo isn’t ideal,
nor is necessarily trying to run away when
you’re already a marked target.
However, it is at least noted that with the
periscope up, U-boats couldn’t go faster
than about 6 knots and, as stated, torpedoes
of the age weren’t terribly accurate or
reliable so the more distance you could get
between you and the U-boat the better.
In the end, these two methods weren’t totally
ineffective, but a better solution was still
needed.
This all got the wheels turning among the
military think tanks, with the result being
some rather humorous proposals as to how to
solve the U-boat problem, with particular
emphasis put on somehow taking out the periscope.
After all, without the periscope, the U-boat’s
only way to target a foe would be to completely
surface, making it a relatively easy target
for more traditional and accurate weaponry.
With proper escorts for the supply ships,
this could easily solve the U-boat problem.
But how to take out the periscope?
A suggestion by the British Board of Invention
and Research was to train seagulls to fly
at the periscopes, which would both make the
presence of the periscope more apparent and
potentially obscure the vision of the person
looking through the periscope long enough
to take action…
To do this, it was suggested that they feed
seagulls in certain regions they wanted protected
through periscope like devices.
Next up, there was a suggestion to simply
put a type of paint in the water with the
hopes that it would get on the periscope lens,
blinding the operator.
Going back to animals, a sea lion trainer
called Joseph Woodward was hired to look into
the possibility of training sea lions to detect
U-boats and then hopefully alert the British
of their presence.
Unfortunately it isn’t known whether this
method was effective, though the Royal Society
does note that the training of at least some
sea lions was performed.
We presume given that the program wasn’t
expanded beyond trials that it wasn’t terribly
effective or perhaps not practical.
As you might imagine, none of these methods
went anywhere.
But this brings us to the rather absurd method
that does seem to have been put into practice.
In the early days of the war, sailors were
put on small patrol boats, all equipped with
the latest and greatest in anti-submarine
technology- large hammers and bags.
They were thus instructed that if they saw
a periscope popping up to the surface, they
were to try to get close to it, then have
one person place a bag over the periscope
while another got their Whack-A-Mole on in
an attempt to destroy it, hopefully all before
any target could be identified and a torpedo
launched.
Exactly how effective this tactic is isn’t
clear but we do know that it was popular enough
for at least one senior officer aboard the
HMS Exmouth to enlist the help of burly blacksmiths
with extra large hammers to patrol with sailors
aboard the smaller boats.
With their amazing hammering abilities, both
in strength and blow accuracy, presumably
it was hoped they’d do a better job than
your average sailor at quickly taking out
a periscope.
Of course, as more sophisticated technologies
were developed, this tactic, sadly, became
obsolete.
But never forget for a brief, but glorious
time in history, there was a guy who could
claim his job was to hunt submarines with
a giant hammer, no doubt giving a cry of “For
Asgard!!!” before smiting his foe.